you don't have to be an extraordinary
person to have success as an
entrepreneur the recipe for success is
not that complicated but it does take a
lot of time and effort and starting the
business is going to be one of the most
challenging time consuming and also
rewarding things that you're ever going
to do in your life what's helped me
number one first and foremost is I love
what I do you have to love what you do
and I love helping entrepreneurs if I
couldn't help entrepreneurs and find a
way to make money doing it then I
probably take two or three jobs on the
side just to make ends meet so i can
smell my time helping entrepreneurs and
that's when you know you're on the right
path whenever I meet entrepreneurs
one-on-one or coffee shops or events and
seminars they often come to me with a
look of defeat you know you've been
working 1800 hours a week nobody
believes in you anymore the word you
have to go back get a job you hate
working for somebody else and within a
few minutes of us talking I see the look
on your face go from despair and it's
believed to excitement and energy and
seeing that change and knowing that
you're going to go home and implement
new ideas into your business and breathe
new life into it energizes me I get
excited I want you to have success I
want you to go home and do that and so
and then I want to go and do it again so
you have to have that passion the core
of every successful business is a deep
love and passion for what you're doing
number two model success whatever you
want to accomplish in life gold find
somebody who's already done what you're
trying to do and learn from them success
leaves clues when I was 19 I had a
software company I had no idea what I
was doing I was a young punk kid scared
I didn't didn't want to fail and have
embarrassment around me and so instead
of panicking I went out and said you
know what I'm not the first guy to go
and try sell software before and I
looked at companies like Microsoft
mcafee into it look at how they got
started I don't care how Bill Gates
makes extra million dollars now but how
do you go from zero to one how do you
make that first million that's what I
wanted to learn and so we copied those
strategies and put them to work for our
business and it was successful so number
one you have to follow your passion
number two you have to model success to
shortcut your pop and number three you
have to not be afraid to take action you
know some things are scary to get
started and you may fall on your face
and you're going to have failures and
that's okay that's part of running the
business you can't be afraid to take
action so I hope that helps that's my
success story I want you to take steps
every day to grow a business don't be
afraid keep doing something every day
even their small steps I'd love to hear
about your six
story if you want to leave it in the
comments below so thank you and I'll see
you soon